le combo de la vie tgap ta soeur hege
plein d'infos sur elle je sais pas si la
reine va ta soeur ta petite soeur c'est
mélissa oui tu nous as donné son numéro
je vais essayer de la mettre en grande
angoisse en grandes races race est parti
avec la voix du corbeau à non à oui
c'est parti mais alors rien mélissa oui
futur tu sors de ton rendez vous
professionnel
[Musique]
pardon c'est qu'on lui toujours tel un
clip audio
[Musique]
résultat j'ai fait que je vois tout mais
je n'ai rien fait qui garde intacte en
jean et tu mets tout le temps car cela
s'applique à la gagnes tu te sentir visé
lui donner tous les merrains c'était
qu'elle a toujours ta table à manger
avec les 2 0
[Rires]
les factures et d'acheter des bottines
way un signe aujourd'hui bas comme d'hab
quoi ouais ok de neige façon sécu mais
fait cuire des titres viennent passer
quelques nuits
oui oui tu es ici typo c'est non mais
t'es fier qu'on l'affecté
c'est toi tu la gare viger couverture en
veuille ou non la leaf est écrit lettre
de la promesse que je suis pas bien non
c'est pas se fixer comme des idiots
parce que c'est payant gillis à zurich
ont visité une clé n a cessé de l'être
[Applaudissements]
mais je dis ça c'est cyril sonné on est
sur le plateau de la grande d'arca avec
amel bent tu connais avarie les attends
je te passe quelqu'un mélissa oui
bonjour c'est laurent baffie
combien ont répondu à cet appel tu viens
quand même de gagner deux billets pour
la grèce je t'embrasse
[Applaudissements]
mélissa les lis ça je te mets à ses
jours en grèce pour deux personnes
[Applaudissements]
si mélissa d'elissalde on à jacques
hamel tu pars en galets mais ni ça tu
t'en fous merci beaucoup d'être rude est
ce que tu sais dans quel hôtel tu pars
tu pars de l'hôtel qui s'appelle la feta
la feta mon but c'est en deux mots un
petit bisou à ta soeur jamais tu tenais
à l'histoire caractère je te dira
[Applaudissements]
mélissa on t'adore tt formidable mais
les voilà d'amal et douce emma c'est mon
garde fous je te fasse très gros bisous
tu appelles après répond ben ammar je
t'embrasse